okay so this is the greatest Batman
Story Ever Told right check this out so
I think we covered the first video a
long long time ago I don't really
remember if we did we're gonna make that
private we're going to cover the whole
thing from scratch basically here
Mariah's been screaming at me for the
last year and a half to cover this story
and I'm finally getting around to
reading it in its entirety and it is
amazing okay let's check this out so
curse is the White Knight right this
basically picks up initially with what
is basically Gotham City back in like
the 1600s and this little segment right
here is going to be exceedingly
important right because what this does
is it picks up initially with a guy
named Edmund Wayne and then a guy by the
name of bakar now the whole situation
here is that you basically have Edmund
Wayne who's kind of depicted as like a
thief to a degree right and he's
ultimately joined by bakar who kind of
brings him on this idea of a mission of
quote unquote purifying the new world
right basically the United States right
because this kind of takes place in Old
England and all that kind of stuff and
so it's really more of like a religious
concept to a degree right like bakar
himself sees himself as kind of a priest
of towards kind of like a warrior priest
you know if you want to call him that
but the idea is that him and Edmund
Wayne traveling to the new world is for
the purpose of getting rid of a curse in
Gotham which is actually manifested in
the form of a guy named laffy Now by all
stand there's a measurement while this
guy laugh he is depicted as a vampire he
is in effect a stand-in for the Joker at
this point in time in really Gotham
City's history now for those of you guys
who are really familiar with Batman and
you're familiar with like Scott Snyder's
run in the new 52 this version of Laffy
has no bearing on like The Pale Man
right to the idea that like Joker had
been taking dionysium and been expanding
his life and so on and so forth this is
a wholly separate thing and they have
nothing to do with each other so I just
wanted to kind of clarify that for those
of you guys who may be a little confused
there the overall gist of this is that
this really is a kind of holy hunt and
that ultimately laffy is basically
defeated and destroyed by bakar and
Edmund Wayne and sort of cast down into
the pits below below Gotham and like
that's basically it he seemingly dies
there now that's the picture that's
given to us this is anything but and
there's like a whole a whole nother set
of events that go into that this is why
I say it's kind of Batman's secret
origin because it's basically going to
take everything you know about Bruce
Wayne and turn it on its head and it
does it in the most amazing way now
having said that and it's a little bit
of a back explanation here which I think
we need and the original Batman the
white knight story what you got was
basically a story where Batman had taken
some pills forced them down the throat
of the Joker which basically quote
unquote made the Joker sane and it
turned him into Jack Napier this is kind
of his regular human self in light of
this Jack Napier had actually reviewed
uh revealed like this huge level of
corruption in the city of Gotham right
in the sense that you had something
called the Batman Devastation fund which
Bruce Wayne didn't know about but what
would literally happen is Batman would
get into a fight with the joker or some
villain it would basically lead to
property values in that place plummeting
then like the ultra wealthy would come
in they'd buy up all those properties
and then they would use the Batman
Devastation fund to basically fix them
up or at least the fund would be used to
fix those properties and because they
were now considered great properties the
wealthy would in turn sell them off or
rent them out to people because they
were now a desirable place to live
because it was just a better place right
gentrifying if you want to call it that
that was just one part of it right there
was corruption in the police force the
whole nine yards but basically Jack
Napier painted Batman to be this guy who
was essentially operating in such a way
to where he was basically lending Gotham
City to a place where the ultra wealthy
could basically capitalize on the things
that he was doing and he was literally
helping to make the rich richer right so
pinning him out to be an enemy of the
people and basically an agent of the
ultra Rich that story was Landmark it
was amazing but what ended up happening
is over time the pills that Jack Napier
was taking began to wear off and he
ultimately reverted back to his Joker
form and so that's why you see him here
as the Joker where he basically was
captured and then put back an arc of
Asylum then he's kind of making his way
through here he goes to his old cell by
basically holding the uh the the warden
of Arkham hostage and then in turn
basically escapes now why he went to his
cell was of particular importance
because what this does here is it
basically switches over to Batman and
Commissioner Gordon on the trail and
really kind of finding out how it was
the Joker managed to escape now there is
some detective work that goes on here
right this idea that you know the the
warden is like well you know I was
stabbed here and they're like no you
weren't you were stabbed there and yada
yada traditional Batman stuff but the
big thing that goes on here is they ask
the question why did the Joker go to his
old cell and leave right he could have
just left right he could have just taken
off and gone anywhere it didn't really
matter why would he why would he make a
stop and then leave that's the question
they have and so what they end up
finding is that within the cell of the
Joker is actually a hidden pathway and
this pathway seemingly leads down into
like this exceedingly old place below
Arkham Asylum and they actually find a
body this bury there now given that
initial intro that we had where laughy's
body was cast down into that giant pit
this initially believe to be him and to
a degree it's just kind of like okay
maybe that's the case they're not
entirely sure because they don't really
know what all they're dealing with here
in fact all they really know is that
there's a body buried here and that's
basically it so they're kind of figuring
out everything that's going on now what
what happens is you pick up with a joker
meeting with a woman named Ruth now the
crazy thing about this is that he kind
of hits her up and says hey like we can
sort of help each other we can sort of
do our thing you know so on and so forth
it's very Cloak and Dagger she is a new
character we don't really know a whole
lot about what's going on here and so
following that what you do is you
basically switch over to a guy named
Jean-Paul Valley now this is one of the
things like the way the story happens it
all kind of takes place super fast in
the beginning so bear with me here dealt
with John Paul Valley he is a guy that
has a long history in DC Comics right he
was introduced back in the early days
during the events of Nightfall when he
was basically the replacement Batman
after Bruce's back was broken by Bane he
does predate that story to a degree but
he's like hyper violent and all that
kind of stuff and the guy is all tied
into religious mysticism and different
things along those lines in reality what
you have here is essentially the same
character but there's more going on and
in fact it's more nuanced and I think
it's better in terms of how he's handled
and curse of the White Knight than he
was in any other way the reality is that
as a janitor in this church he kind of
starts losing his mind sort of starts
hallucinating going crazy and then
ultimately ends up being met by
basically the Joker who appears in this
almost kind of Messianic form right
holding this giant sword and then
basically preaching to uh the janitor by
preaching to Jean-Paul Valley that he
can bring him back to the guy that like
curses the wicked or punishes the wicked
and all that kind of stuff feeding back
into that religious concept that
Jean-Paul Valley had before now again
there aren't a lot of questions being
answered here but the reality is you
basically have John Paul Valley who's
presented with a flaming sword and he
ultimately ends up undertaking the
moniker of becoming Azrael now for the
other things that take place here it is
kind of Batman to a degree coming to
terms with everything that's going on
here one of the things that they find of
course with him basically analyzing the
bones and then studying it they
basically end up learning that this is
basically a guy by the name of Lafayette
Arkham and that there was a kind of
story that was told by parents to their
kids specifically Commissioner Gordon to
his daughter Barbara kind of telling a
rhyme right laffy Arkham in the wood
eating children when he could underneath
a moon of blood Swept Away Before the
Flood basically that kind of a thing and
that he was sort of depicted as a
vampire to a degree and in fact it looks
like he actually was but this is very
reminiscent of like the court of owls
and Sean Murphy is the writer is kind of
building on that right that's one of the
things to know ever since Scott Snyder
took over writing Batman and he created
the court of owls it's always been kind
of a landmark thing or kind of a major
tie-in to Batman stories ever since
because it was so popular when it
happened now they don't know exactly why
it was that he was there they don't know
exactly what's going on but what we do
find out is that following the death of
Alfred and a note that was left to him
that Batman ends up finding a chest that
was contained below or within the
quarters of Alfred and in that chest is
basically a journal and the journal was
given to Batman at that point in time
because Alfred felt like he was ready
for it so it's kind of these small
little pieces that are basically sort of
coming together to a degree and they all
do come together in a cohesive unit
right as a cohesive whole it is a pretty
cool moment because following that what
we end up doing is picking up with Ruth
showing up to Bruce Wayne and this was
an important thing because this is when
we finally start finding out what's
going on with her character that these
pieces coming together first come
together with Ruth when Ruth visits
Bruce Wayne one of the things to
remember is that because of everything
that had happened in Batman The White
Knight which again I'll have that video
down in the playlist I highly suggest
you guys go back and watch it that what
we had found out is that basically
Batman trying to reinstill trust in the
city of Gotham intends to publicly
reveal his identity to everybody in that
City now that's when Ruth shows up and
she kind of asked the question is that
something that you really want to do
right now remember the Batman
Devastation fund exists out there and
it's literally just a giant pile of
money that the ultra wealthy tap into
the truth about this is that if Batman
walks away from being Batman right if
Bruce Wayne leaves the mantle behind he
hands everything over to basically the
new Gotham City task force right that
basically serves more of what Batman
would traditionally do by dealing with
criminals and so on and so forth and
Batman just doesn't really exist in in
Gotham City anymore the Batman
Devastation fund would go away and so
Ruth basically being an agent of what
are quote unquote the elite right the
wealthiest individuals in Gotham shows
up here to basically strong Armin right
and it's just kind of like is this
something that you really want to do
because if you did think of the
ramifications this would have right what
she's doing here is not that dissimilar
from like a cop right who like kills a
person and the and and like a district
attorney says Hey like we need to bring
up charges against that cop and some
nameless faceless person from the police
Union shows up in their office and says
hey look district attorney you could
bring charges against that cop and and
you could hold them accountable but God
you know if you did
it would be it would just be a shame to
know that if somebody broke into your
house there wouldn't really be any
police officers who'd be able to respond
like imagine how terrible how awful that
situation would be imagine what might
happen to your wife or your husband or
your children right imagine what might
happen there so there's just something
to keep in mind if you decide to go
forward with this that's literally what
she's doing here right she's like if you
did this imagine the effects of your
public identity having on like your
friends or what's left of your family or
the people who know you imagine the pain
you might be causing them Bruce Wayne
imagine what the villains would do and
imagine if those villains had Financial
backing from a mystery source and they
were able to do things that they weren't
normally able to do just something to
keep in mind Bruce Wayne and then she
ultimately leaves right literally trying
to strong-arm Bruce Wayne and so it's
kind of a crazy thing because following
that you pick up with Commissioner
Gordon who speaks publicly following
everything going on with Jack Napier now
this is one of the cool things for those
of you guys who never really a red curse
or red the White Knight this will really
fill in everything quite easily right
what he says is he literally says you
know as you guys know I'm not a
politician right I'm not good at like
spin I'm not good at telling you what
you want to hear I'm good at telling you
the truth right he's like I don't like
cameras or any of that kind of stuff
right and I have no patience for any of
that nonsense he said so I'm going to
break the rules of politics and be
honest with you guys I hated Jack Napier
right unlike the voters I didn't have
the luxury of ignoring all the horrible
things that the Joker did to his victims
and I was stunned when he got elected as
councilman suddenly I didn't recognize
the city I was living in I felt betrayed
because remember one of the things that
people had done is that even though Jack
Napier was basically the Joker who'd
been made been made sane right the pills
made of a regular person that they voted
him in as councilman and the response of
of Jim Gordon and a lot of people out
there in a position of power who had
dealt with the joker before was okay yes
Jack Napier is the Joker who's saying so
sure I guess they're separate people but
these are things he's done in the past
but the reality is it was politics 101
and Jack Napier knew that right the the
idea of politics is you don't tell
people the truth you tell them what they
want to hear that's how you get elected
to office right like people want to live
in a fantasy world and if you feed them
that fantasy they will reward you with
political power right that's how people
are and so once when Jack Napier
realized that that's how he got elected
and so that's why you have Commissioner
Gordon saying like for a long time I
refuse to believe that Jack Napier was a
different person than the Joker that
buried inside Gotham's worst criminal
was Gotham's best chance at moving
forward but I was wrong right Jack
Napier was not the Joker and while he
wasn't perfect he did show us how to be
better and that's why we created the
Napier initiative as commissioner I
ended police corruption address the
problems in places like that port and
supported programs like the GTO but the
root of our problem isn't our streets
it's in our Ivory Towers it's the ultra
Rich it's the people out there who
operate with impunity and he says that's
why I'm asking for your support give me
the power to stop the so-called Elites
not as your commissioner but as your
mayor and the funny thing about that is
that in the middle of all this The Joker
appears right like literally The Joker
shows up and he basically well he goes
to shoot Commissioner Gordon not
necessarily he doesn't really do a good
job of it in fact Commissioner Gordon
just kind of beats the crap out of Jack
Napier like like hummles him but the
whole thing about this is literally the
Joker's like here's the thing guys you
can listen to what this guy's telling
you and you can listen to him saying he
wants to clean everything up but the
reality here is Commissioner Gordon is
about as inept of a cop as anyone can be
right like this guy's terrible like not
only is he an inept police officer he's
a cheating husband he's a terrible
father he's so stupid he's such a
terrible Detective he didn't even know
his daughter was operating as Batgirl
and literally Joker broadcast to
everybody in the city of Gotham who
Batgirl's identity is and so at that
point you literally switch over to John
Paul Valley right to Azrael who appears
before Ruth and that's when you find out
what his role in all of this is that
what Ruth says is okay we're not going
to be able to get Batman to play ball
we're not going to be able to get Bruce
Wayne to step down as Batman in any
meaningful way if he does it won't be a
way that works for us so we need
somebody to replace him so they're
bringing in Jean-Paul Valley to
basically take out Batman and then to
replace Batman and effectively be their
agent here's the thing they don't know
what they're getting into right like you
guys remember that line from from what
is it the Dark Knight when Alfred was
talking to Batman and he was telling him
about how like they hammered on the
criminal Enterprise or the criminal
entities so hard that at the end of the
day they turned to a man they didn't
fully understand that's what's happening
here right they're turning to a guy they
they don't fully grasp and even we as
the audience don't necessarily know the
full background of Jean-Paul Valley and
how he got to where he was but the truth
about this is that in this story much
like in the main DC Universe Jean-Paul
Valley is not beholden to the ultra
wealthy he's a man on his own mission
and so what this woman says is we can
give you all the arms and Armament that
you need to support you and your team
right we can make that happen all we
need you to do is to play ball with us
and to do things our way and John Paul
Valley ever the guy who's willing to do
whatever it takes to complete his goal
ultimately says sure and signs on for it
and Dons what is quite possibly the
single greatest Azrael costume ever
devised by man it is dude if this thing
looks dull and I gotta tell you guys man
anybody who shows up to a Comic-Con
cosplaying is John Paul Valley and looks
anything close to this is gonna be like
the focal point of that Comic-Con right
like everybody's gonna be want to get
pictures of that guy because that
costume is insane and just to give you
guys perspective on how capable this guy
is right like literally Jean-Paul Valley
and his team they hack into the bat cave
right while Batman's like literally
going through this cave and he's like
analyzing this document right this
journal and so on right asriel and them
hack into it right natural literally
says the brothers were to divide the
land and live in peace but then one son
Rose against the other like Cain and
Abel God cursed Cain for what he'd done
just as he cursed you just as he cursed
all of Gotham I am Vengeance I am God's
Wrath here to break the curse to rise up
against you and deliver this land from
Evil after three centuries the house of
Wayne will finally be rectified and so
literally what happens is the forces of
Azrael hijacked the bat the Batmobile
right they literally hijacked Batman's
car and they have it start firing on
Batman they literally take over every
form of technology in the bat cave and
use it against Bruce Wayne this guy the
only thing he can do is just Flee for
his [ __ ] life that's sort of the only
thing that Batman can do he just gets
out as fast as he possibly can before he
gets sprayed down before he gets
destroyed now having said that the thing
that Azrael says here that's what I want
you to remember here the thing that
Azrael says right after three centuries
the house of Wayne will finally be
recognized one brother Rising against
another that's the Central Point among
all of this right the central focal
point here with everything that's going
on that's what I want you to focus on
now of course Bruce Wayne Right this
being a comic about Batman Bruce Wayne
he makes it out in one piece right what
would a Batman comic be if Bruce Wayne
dies like two or three issues in right
so it'd be kind of nonsensical he
survives but he's rescued by like Harvey
Bullock and basically Dick Grayson now
remember Dick Grayson is not Robin here
but because of everything that's going
on and because Dick Grayson needed help
here he had to tell Harvey Bullock that
Bruce Wayne is Batman he had to reveal
that identity now what Batman also does
is he kind of reveals the situation
going on with like Ruth and all that
kind of stuff you know what not them
trying to strong arm her but what we
also get is him offering an explanation
in terms of what's going on here
regarding the events of of like the
Wayne's and bakar and all that kind of
stuff and so what he reveals here is he
brings out a medallion right and he says
that Edmund Wayne was the first Wayne in
Gotham that he came here to claim his
land from the criminals who'd stolen it
right and so what he says is Edmund was
not alone he had a partner named bakar
who wore this symbol and Edmund was
supposed to give bakar half his land in
exchange for his health that the deal
that was made is that bakar would help
Edmund basically recapture the Wayne
lands right Gotham City effectively or
at least the place that became Gotham
City in exchange for that bacard would
get half of it right that was the deal
that was made and so the questions asked
so this guy who blew up your house is a
descendant of bakar or that the Joker
convinced us that he is and so in the
end the reality is that Bruce Wayne just
does doesn't have all the cards this is
what he's kind of pieced together so far
right this is what he's kind of brought
together so far but again like this
whole origin we'll get to by the end of
this right this is gonna be a lengthy
video just FYI guys it's gonna be kind
of a host right a big chunky one but it
is a cool thing because Batman does the
only logical thing to do here which is
to go and find the Joker right and to
ask the Joker this question because if
the Joker discovered this secret the
Joker's holding on to the secret then
the Joker's the only one that has the
answer to this right but here's the
thing when Batman gets there and he
starts talking to him that at the end of
the day he asks like what's going on
with Jean-Paul Valley and the Joker
literally says like he's my knight right
the elites are my pawns that Ruth is my
queen check the move is yours right that
kind of a thing so basically Joker kind
of set the pieces in motion but he's
sitting back watching it all happen he's
sitting back and watching it all unfold
and so when Batman mentions Lafayette
Arkham that's when he seems to reveal to
the Joker that he basically has all
these little pieces here and there and
so what the Joker says is okay that
basically Joker found the secrets right
he found out what was going on here in
the city of Gotham and that what Jack
Napier had told Batman is that the Joker
had found these secrets and that was
quote unquote when the Joker was created
that laffy told him a joke that was
written in blood the greatest joke in
all of Gotham and it's a joke that only
did the Joker himself knows the truth
about the Wayne family that it's all
built on lies that none of it's true and
that ultimately Joker's been laughing
ever since waiting for the right moment
to reveal this Grand Finale and he
finally gets to share it so while he
doesn't really give a whole lot of
information to to Batman himself what he
does reveal is I know the truth of
Gotham's Origins and I know the truth of
where the wanes come from and what I
know is that everything you believe
about your family history is a lie
everything you think you know about
what's going on is completely and
totally false and so one of the things
that Batman does here is he actually
brings in Harley Quinn who's pregnant
now one of the things to remember is
that Harley and Jack Napier that she had
basically orchestrated everything that
had gone on with regarding to trying to
make Jack Napier sane the situation of
like Batman chasing after Jack
presenting him with the pills forcing
The Fill of the pills down his throat
all that kind of stuff right because
Harley genuinely believed that the Joker
could be cured she just needed to
engineer a situation where that would
happen but she also got herself Knocked
Up by Jack Napier and now she's preggers
with twins and so the hope of Batman is
that he can bring her in and she can
somehow quote unquote reach the Jack
Napier Persona in the mind of the Joker
which doesn't really seem to work
because the reality here is that the
Jack Jack Navy Persona just kind of
seems to be gone Joker has full and
Total Control now and so there's
seemingly no way to get him back to a
state of normalcy and so what this does
is it leads to Batman and it leads to
Harley Quinn digging deeper and trying
to find other information within this
hole that the Joker had discovered maybe
there's something that they missed there
now they do find writing on the wall
that seems to be written in blood but
they can't really figure out exactly
what it says because it was wiped Away
by The Joker or at least enough of it
was wiped away that Batman can't figure
out what it says but what he also finds
is that there's another body that was
buried down there outside of Laffy
Lafayette himself right like there's
something else there now the goal of
course is to dig that body up and Define
an answer to it but before they can you
have Commissioner Gordon who's caught up
to by by asriel right and it's really
him like asriel just kind of going after
Gordon and just the next person on his
list right the person that he's going
after what ends up happening here though
and what's what it seems to be kind of a
running theme going on in DC right now
is that Commissioner Gordon is
ultimately killed by Azrael right
literally stabs him through the chest
because he sees Commissioner Gordon as a
person one working against the elites
but two as a source of corruption and
sin because he was a part of that
corruption at one point in time that's
one of the things to keep in mind about
Azrael like yes he's kind of working for
the elites what the elites don't know is
that they are on the list of asriel he
will come after them eventually but the
truth about it is that his Allegiance is
to punishing the wicked and the sinful
that's really where his Allegiance is it
just happens to be that for the moment
that the the goals of the elites and uh
and Ezreal himself are aligned once that
alignment ends it's all like Donkey Kong
right like it's crazy it gets really
really cool but literally Commissioner
Gordon is killed here in that moment
once Barbara Gordon finds out what's
going on she immediately takes off she
tries to find Gordon right Gordon of
course is basically dead and she
immediately starts screaming at
everybody who's there because they
weren't there when Gordon died right
like where were you why weren't you
protecting him why weren't you keeping
him safe now the reality here is that
they didn't know Azrael was going after
Commissioner Gordon and in fact
Commissioner Gordon meeting with who he
thought was Batman if for him it just
seemed business as usual it wasn't until
Azrael revealed himself that he realized
this isn't Batman this is actually just
asriel pretending to be Batman and that
was it right like there was there was
really no means of Escape here so in
reality everybody was seemingly tricked
by asriel there really wasn't anything
they could have done here and even like
Barbara Gordon lashing out at everybody
it's her just kind of going through this
emotional pain and torment of her father
being killed and as most of you guys
know for us as human beings whenever we
lose something close to us rationality
takes a back seat and we're just looking
for a reason to understand there has to
be a reason this happened it couldn't
have just been the wrong place at the
wrong time or my dad was just duped
somebody has to be at fault here and
while it is asriel she's literally
channeling all that Fault in all the
wrong directions there's only so much
she can do and so what ends up going on
is that you have this kind of story
that's told to Bruce Wayne when he goes
to visit Leslie Tompkins now Leslie
Tompkins is the one that's basically
helping Harley Quinn give birth to her
kids those of you guys who aren't
familiar with their character Leslie
Tompkins has historically kind of been
like well she was a precursor to it but
those of you guys coming from Marvel
Comics she was Night Nurse right she was
basically the nurse that would tend to
like superheroes sometimes villains
depending on the situation but she was
most closely related to Batman right
right in the sense that like Bruce Wayne
would like show up to Leslie Tompkins
and she would basically help him deal
with his injuries or something along
those lines sometimes feed him
information because of the fact that she
kind of had her ear to the ground and so
on and so forth but there's a very close
history there but what she says is that
she's aware of the journal and its
existence you know that she knew that
Alfred had it in his possession and that
the way this had played out is that they
had discovered it at a previous point in
time and not fully knowing everything
that was going on they had gone to visit
a guy in an alley they'd never heard of
at a hospital that they didn't know
existed right like an old Pharmacy is
what it's referred to once they get down
there they meet a guy who basically has
red hair with a white stripe now for
those of you guys who are familiar with
DC Comics you know exactly who this is
when I was reading this I was like is
that who I think it is is that who I
think it is you end up finding out later
on it is Jason blood right which is
really really cool it was amazing to see
those of you guys who are familiar with
Jason blood he's the guy that basically
holds a curse where he's basically
inexorably tied to a guy by the name of
etrigan so that's literally Jason
blood's thing right he says Gone Gone
the form of man arise the demon etragon
he's very closely tied into the DC side
of things with like John Constantine
Swamp Thing so on and so forth part of
that dark magic and mysticism sort of
thing when it comes to DC Comics but he
basically ends up talking to to Alfred
and those guys and what he says is that
this journal that he has in his
possession that he had handed over to
Alfred that he had basically taken it
from The Joker The Joker was the first
one to Discover It Again The Joker had
found this journal in all those
documents when he had found himself in
that hole and that the joke I'm sorry
the journal itself is basically a
warning but he ends up presenting it and
saying like you need to give this to
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne needs to know
about this maybe not right now but he
needs to know when the time is right
because at the time this meeting is
taking place between Alfred and Leslie
and Jason blood this is taking place
right around the time when Bruce Wayne
first started acting as Batman he wasn't
like the polished version he's like you
know figuring it out he's kind of been
Batman for like a year or two or
something like that but now is not not
the time to present him with any of that
information but literally Jason says
when the time comes you need to present
this to him he has every right to know
about the truth and the history of the
Wayne family and so before they can
really do anything else Jason blood and
everything around them vanish they quite
literally disappear in front of their
faces and so that's why this is being
presented to Bruce Wayne at this moment
right now what you also end up finding
here is that there is basically a map
that shows the landscape of Gotham back
at that point in time but the maths
don't line up right the current form of
Gotham as it exists now is not the same
as the the way the way the map shows
there's a huge chunk of the area that's
missing that it can't be lined up and so
what basically seems to happen or seem
to indicate is that a portion of Gotham
was flooded somewhere along the line
they don't entirely know how they just
know that it was so now the question
becomes what lies at the base of this
section of Gotham that's basically been
flooded and why was it flooded why did
did happen in the first place and so
before any of these questions can be
answered the word basically reaches the
ears of Bruce Wayne that asriel's on the
move and in fact Barbara ends up
catching up to them right Batgirl shows
up to asriel and tries to take all of
them out now the reality here is she's
fighting recklessly and she's fighting
full of emotion and anger and while that
emotion and anger is being channeled in
the right direction the first thing
Bruce Wayne would tell her is this is
foolish right it's a foolish thing for
you to do because the truth is that
fighting with emotion and anger all you
have to do is make a mistake and your
enemy will gain the upper hand in this
case you're talking about guys like
Azrael you're talking about Jean-Paul
Valley who by this point is kind of a
mystery in terms of how they function
but ex-military training is what
everybody's seemingly picking up on
right these guys are functioning like
some older military group and so they
fight with Precision Jean-Paul Valley
gets the upper hand on Barbara Gordon
immediately and literally Banes the
scroll in the sense that like he breaks
her back right literally just seems to
to paralyze this girl even if I'm
momentarily Batman steps in and the
reality is as capable as Batman is John
Paul Valley gets the upper hand quite
readily and they ultimately leave right
like the like literally the response of
of Jean-Paul Valley's forces is like we
have to leave here right like the forces
of the of the cops are showing up here
we can't fight all those guys we can't
overpower all of them so in the moment
asriel got the upper hand on Batman he
beat him and he was going to kill him
right but of course they end up
basically taking off and uh and kind of
leave Batman to grab Barbara Gordon and
take her back to a place of recovery but
at that point what you have are two
things going on at the same time the
first is you have the funeral of
Commissioner Gordon which most everybody
attends and the second thing is that you
have Batman who does not attend that
funeral instead what Batman does is he
goes to the section of Gotham City which
seems to have been flooded and he starts
exploring it and what he finds is that
way down right deep below these Waters
that you have what looks like this older
little village and in this old little
village you've got a cross that belongs
to to a group called The Church of Saint
Dumas and so what Batman does is he
pieces everything together and he
literally says okay right meeting with
Barbara Gordon meeting with Dick Grayson
this is when Batman seemingly figures
out all the pieces right he gets
everything together and this one he
makes his presentation and he says okay
so here's what's actually going on here
right I figured out the actual origin of
Gotham he says that we've always
believed that Gotham began as a small
village on the coast that's why the
journal's map is so strange it places
the village in the wrong place on the
edge of a large Bay that extended Inland
in an area that we now know as the
Gotham Reservoir but the journal is
accurate I found the Lost settlement
beneath the reservoir someone tried to
erase our early history by flooding it
and when the questions asked who did
this the response of Batman is Edmund
Wayne right that was Arkham dead right
Lafayette Arkham basically being killed
Edmund had reclaimed his inheritance but
rather than honoring his promise to give
car half of Gotham Edmund killed him
right as Lord of Gotham he convinced the
British to help him Purge the entire
Valley so they could turn it into one of
the most valuable ports in the new world
that he erased all evidence of the car
and the chapel of Saint Dumas by damning
the river and flooding the valley and
that all the Villagers lost their homes
those who couldn't afford to leave were
resettled in a place that we now call
backport that Edmund redrew the
coastline as the land below the lake
dried up then he built a new settlement
by selling property to the East India
Company that's the truth about Gotham
about how the Wayne Fortune started in
the new world and that's why Jokers sent
Azrael after me by Reviving The
Descendant of bakar Joker wants to
expose the cover-up and destroy the
Wayne Legacy that basically asriel
seemingly knows all of this right and
that's why Azrael is going after Batman
it's a blood Feud right your ancestor
killed my ancestors so now I'm gonna
kill you in return here's the crazy
thing about this none of this is true
Batman's got it all wrong
he's got it all wrong and it's a it's
it's amazing it's one of these instances
where Batman tries to put it all
together and Batman gets the pieces put
wrong so here's the question what's the
actual truth okay so let's get into this
right I know you guys think I'm Gonna
Leave You on a cliffhanger I'm not I
told you this is going to be a beefy
video right so let's get into this right
one of the things that happens is you
have Harley Quinn who goes to visit
Joker in the belief or under the belief
that she can talk to Jack and Jack can
give her the information that the Joker
won't reveal but remember almost nobody
can get the Jack Napier Persona out of
the Joker right just it seems to be too
far gone so when she shows up with her
kids in tow right her twins in toe she
tries to talk to the Joker she tries to
get Jack Napier's personality to come
out but it just can't be done and the
Joker even just kind of makes fun of her
and laughs at it right like I love this
idea that you really believe that you
can like reach into Jack Napier and you
can somehow get his personality to come
out it's adorable and it's cute but like
it's not gonna happen right none of
that's going to take place and so she
ultimately says okay fine goodbye Jack
like I love you and that's when the Jack
Napier Persona snaps back right that
just Declaration of love but the next
thing you end up doing is picking up on
the Gotham City Police Department that
have a blood sample of Azrael when they
test this they end up basically handing
it over to one of the guys who has an
ex-mil or has a military contact this
military contact hands over a whole
bunch of classified evidence and this
guy basically says Okay so the deal
behind this is that this guy's Jean-Paul
Valley right and an ex-green Beret right
a military vet this guy is Special
Forces he's the best of the best right
that's literally what this guy is he's
ridiculously capable and so what ends up
going on is they're like we have to be
aware because the team he has working
for him these guys are hardcore right
they were a wet work team back in the
day toppling governments all that kind
of stuff they specialize in taking out
guys like us and so what ends up
happening is that you have you kind of
jump back to Harley Quinn talking with
Jack Napier and Jack Napier kind of
reveals everything that's been going on
from the perspective of the Joker
because remember while the Jack Napier
Persona hasn't really been prevalent
during all of this he remembers and sees
everything the Joker's done and so what
he says is like okay the Joker
discovered the secret of what was going
on with with Gotham's history right he's
like I can't remember the details of the
secret The Joker discovered but he
discovered the secret what he did is he
basically went to Azrael and then woke
up the part of him that had all that
military training showing him his old
history and saying this is the actual
history of Gotham this is what happened
to your descendant now's your chance to
take to basically get your revenge
that's how Azrael ended up being quote
unquote reactivated and going back to
the person that he was before at that
point you end up having uh end up having
Harley Quinn that asked him like do you
recall everything The Joker discovered
when it was down in that cave and that
that you end up having Jack that says
yes I remember everything he said I
remember what was written on the wall
the problem is that if bat if I tell you
this you can never tell Batman you can
never tell Batman what was written on
the wall because if that happens it'll
destroy him it'll completely and utterly
destroy him and so ultimately Harley
Quinn agrees and Jack Napier tells
Harley what was written on the wall now
before we get into that what we end up
doing is jumping back to Azrael when he
finally meets back with Ruth now
remember one of the things that I told
you is that she's Allied herself with
John Paul Valley not fully understanding
what she was getting into and so she
presents him with what is basically a
mechanized Batman suit but what she says
is like you can't be our agent anymore
you're too much of a liability we
brought you in so you could secretly
kill Batman not so you could literally
tear the town apart trying to destroy
the guy you're drawing too much heat
you're making too much noise you're too
loud man and so it's like you can't but
you can't play this role anymore but
that's when he tells her my Vendetta
here extends far beyond your petty
schemes of trying to make sure the rich
stay richer and some Batman s character
can Ensure sure like the Batman Davis
station fun stays intact and all that
kind of stuff and so what he tells her
is like this sword that I have this is a
flaming sword there's a special kind of
napalm in my Scabbard right I pull the
sword I press a button and the sword
ignites or I can just pull the sword and
nothing happens and so with her
realizing this is effectively a threat
and this guy intends to take her out she
calls in bang now the crazy thing about
this is under any normal circumstance
Bane is more than a match for virtually
anybody not here man basically Bane gets
wrecked by Jean-Paul Valley like
literally Jean-Paul Valley takes this
guy out until Bane starts humping you
know amping up the Venom in his body
increasing his strength and durability
and all that kind of stuff when that
happens what ends up going on is the
forces of Jean-Paul Valley overpower
Bane and they literally decapitate him
right they cut his head right off and so
like that's the end of Bane at that
point Jean-Paul Valley takes a sword out
of the Scabbard with no flames they tie
down Ruth he sits the sword on her and
he says okay so here's what's going to
happen you're going to give me the
information that I need you're going to
give me The Client List for all the
elites that exist here in Gotham I'm
going to go after them all and I'm going
to kill them all they're all Sinners
they all deserve to die and when she
initially refuses to do it he says okay
so remember this sword has Napalm on it
so he takes a candle and he sits it on
the sword and he's like anything that's
a fire can ignite this sword you have
until this candle burns down and the
sword ignites and you burn alive to give
me the information that I need and so
that's when she starts dumping all the
info in the end it still doesn't matter
he kills her and everybody else with the
joker still locked up right the Joker
hadn't been caught and then locked up in
Arkham Asylum then what ends up
happening is Jean-Paul Valley shows up
and he kills every villain every single
villain in Arkham Asylum he massacres
them all right literally wearing this
Batman mechanized suit and is like I'm
the new Batman now meets up with The
Joker and then him and the Joker kind of
start going on a bit of a rampage kind
of but not really their goal is to
capture the Joker and their goal is to
get information from the joker now the
problem is once Gotham City Police
Department arrives on the scene both at
where Ruth was where she's basically
killed and Bane's decapitated as well as
the prison where Joker was broken out
you end up having Batman who goes to
visit Jason blood in the same way that
Leslie Tompkins and Alfred had done and
this is where you get the backstory of
basically Jean-Paul Valley and what
Jason says is that he is part of a
member of the Order of Saint Dumas that
unlike the main DC Universe where it's a
clandestine Church organization that
exists out there that here in this story
Jason blood is the one who runs it that
he came across Azrael or Jean-Paul
Valley when he was a kid and he had
tried to teach him to be a soldier to be
a knight of the Order of Saint Dumas the
problem with this is that where those
guys are trained as assassins they're
highly capable that there was a kind of
darkness in Jean-Paul Valley and as a
result of that that Jason blood could
only do so much but the reality here is
that Jason realized that when it came to
Jean-Paul Valley he was just too extreme
that he just couldn't really be
maintained and as a result of that they
ended up casting him out of the order
now the other part of this is that he
talks to Batman about the journal and
everything with with Edmund Wayne and
Batman reveals like I know the story of
what's going on here right I know that
like Edmund Wayne killed the car and all
that kind of stuff you know all that
information and that's when Jason
blood's like okay but see that's the
thing though you're wrong about
everything right that's that's the if
that's really what you think Bruce Wayne
you put all the pieces like you put this
puzzle together wrong you have the
pieces in the wrong place that's not
what happened I'm not going to tell you
what's happened but what I am going to
tell you is there's a lot more going on
here the only thing that he's willing to
willing to reveal here is that he says
there's more to the story than what's in
the journal the Order of Saint Dumas had
sent the car to Gotham on a quest to
bring peace to the valley right to save
the lost souls by teaching them the word
of God that he was designed to be a
missionary and he says but rather than
convert the Sinners he ultimately joined
them so we banished him from the order
and he says that's the issue is that
when it came down to this that bakar
wouldn't go quietly right he wanted
Vengeance so he seized power by finding
the last Wane right finding Edmund Wayne
and he says once they arrived here bakar
said his plan in motion in order to
overthrow the criminal Empire of Gotham
bakar insisted they pose as criminals
themselves they became thieves and
Smugglers getting to know every pirate
kidnapper who passed through Gotham they
studied and they learned their
weaknesses they got close with them and
so it wasn't long before Edmund fell
under Gotham's spell and that's what
this Valley does to people it seduces
them right for two years bakar waited
biting his time and allowing Edmund's
heart to become as dark as the men they
swore to overthrow once Edmund's
transformation was complete there was
only one thing left for bakar to do and
that was to turn him into a killer it
was the only way to reclaim Gotham them
by eliminating everybody who stood in
their way they started at the Docks and
worked their way up to the highest cliff
the home of Laffy Arkham the vampire of
Gotham Valley with laffy gone the two
men were supposed to divide the valley
in half but bakar had other plans and so
that's when Batman's kind of like okay
so Edmund didn't kill bakar In Cold
Blood he was just defending himself
right he kind of asked this question and
that's when Jason blood is like I'm not
going to give you all the answers Bruce
but all I can tell you is this I believe
God has a path for everyone and is up to
each of us to discover our own truths
and that's basically it that's all the
information that he gets so he gets a
little bit of a correction in terms of
his perception of what's going on but
the reality is he doesn't get the whole
picture and so what ends up happening is
you basically have Batman working
alongside Harley Quinn trying to figure
out the larger piece of this puzzle and
the two of them basically end up racing
back to Arkham Asylum now one of the
things that goes on I'm not entirely
sure how much I agree with you do have
the Joker that basically kidnaps the
kids of Harley Quinn in order to draw
out both Batman and Harley Quinn kind of
a weird situation but it does draw
Batman directly to uh to Arkham because
that's where Jean-Paul Valley is waiting
for him under any normal circumstance
Batman would probably blow it off and
come back and so you know at some point
later or deal with the situation but
knowing Harley Quinn and knowing Batman
cares about Harley Quinn then if she
shows up and she says you know like the
Joker kidnap my kids you have to help me
get them Batman's gonna race back over
there and so it's cool because you do
kind of have this moment where the Joker
kind of bounces back and forth between
Jack Napier and his normal self or I
guess is his Joker myself and you do
have him talking to Harley but one of
the things that Jack Napier tries to do
is that he does take over a momentarily
long enough for Harley to get her kids
back and he literally tells her like I'm
like I have to kill myself of the only
way to get rid of the Joker but the
Joker won't necessarily let him do it
and so it's him trying to do whatever he
can to keep the Joker from taking the
kids back or killing Harley it's kind of
a mixed in a weird situation it is cool
and it is tragic he does give Harley
Quinn the gun The Joker was using so
that if the time comes she can pull the
trigger like she needs to but the
reality here is with the fight between
Batman and and uh and Azrael this one's
a lot more interesting because as the
fight unfolds between the two of them
right as this fight goes down you kind
of have asriel saying like the truth
about what you've done here is your
ancestor killed my ancestor right this
place belongs to me right it's it's it's
my territory right like it's it's my
land your ancestor took it over right
your entire lineage is one of betrayal
and that's where things are are really
kind of funny is because what ends up
happening the Joker chimes in and he's
like you've got it wrong right you have
everything wrong here it was not bakar
who died next to Laffy it was Advent
Edmond Wayne was the one who died there
and when Batman's like what are you
talking about the response to the Joker
is with laffy Arkham dead bakar's plan
was almost complete all he needed to do
was eliminate Edmund all he had to do
was kill that guy that was the last
thing he had to do which is exactly what
he did he killed Edmund Wayne then he
could steal his identity flood the
valley and start rebuilding Gotham On My
Own by Edmund barely survived the fall
into the well and what he did in his own
blood what was written on the wall is I
am Edmund Wayne and that bakar was
basically an imposter and so the reality
here is that Bruce Wayne is not
descended from the Wayne family he's not
the son of of Edmund Wayne he's the son
of bakar right like literally his entire
lineage is a lie right bakar stole the
identity of Edmund Wayne passed himself
off as Edmund Wayne started popping out
kids left and right and so in in truth
like what's really going on here is that
it's all false none of it's real man and
it's the most insane Revelation ever The
Joker even says that right he's like
that's why I'm always smiling Batman
because of the joke I was told in
Edmond's tomb that Gotham's greatest
hero is descended from criminals you're
using a stolen Fortune to wage a war on
crime that your family helped to create
don't you get it you're not really a
Wayne asriel is Azrael is the only way
to hear right it's crazy so like Azrael
is the rightful heir to all this
territory to all this land and so it's
it's a ridiculously insane Revelation
now of course once that Revelation comes
to fruition and Batman realizes he's not
a Wayne and he never was that John Paul
Valley is the only Wayne standing here
then of course you have Harley Quinn who
pulls the gun pulls the trigger and
basically kills the Joker on the spot
but with that being said guys I'm Gonna
Leave You guys on a cliffhanger man
because honestly I haven't read the last
two issues yet I need to we'll be back
next week thank you all for watching I
will catch you all later peace